robert spencer there's a tradition as i
understand it
uh from the 9th century in islam and the
saying goes there is no god but allah
and kuipham is his prophet now
i was always taught the prophet is named
muhammad how does islam justify two
names for its founder
it's uh actually not a tradition of that
actual phrase but just a tradition in
ibn saad who's a 9th century biographer
of muhammad that he was originally named
kuthon and this indicates that
there were likely several people of
different names whose who had stories
told about them and their stories were
folded into the muhammad legend that
makes perfect sense but if you believe
that there was a man named muhammad who
lived from 570 to 632 and these are the
stories of his life then there's no
reason for anybody ever to have invented
that he was at one point called by
another name
and so uh this is yet another strike
against the traditional canonical
account of islam's origins and
muhammad's life
you